good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric Gershon our guest today is
philosopher shelly kagan a popular
professor here at Yale and also in China
where he's won a devoted following for
his Yale Open course on death today
we'll talk with Shelley about what death
is how he thinks about it and we'll ask
him some of your questions thanks for
being with us Shelley it's my pleasure
thank you for having me
so Shelley death is a pretty broad topic
let's narrow it a little bit when you
contemplate death what kinds of
questions are you not thinking about
what aspects of death you not consider
well there's a lot of questions you
might raise in thinking about death
broadly there are questions about
grieving or the process of dying
biologically physiologically speaking
there is the attitudes we have in a
society about the the dead or the dying
I don't discuss such sociological
anthropological or psychological
questions I think about philosophical
questions concerning what happens when
we die whether there's a soul might
there be some possibility of surviving
the death of our body there are
questions about the ways in which death
is bad for us whether immortality would
be a good thing whether we should be
afraid of death whether suicides ever
morally justified those are the sorts of
questions I tend to focus on most of us
avoid death as long as we can most of us
don't think about it all that often what
is the value that you have found in
thinking long and hard about it well
it's one of the central aspects of the
human condition that not only that were
alive were alive now but that our life
is followed by death and throughout
human history as long as people have
been thinking they've been trying to
understand death we've been trying to
understand death to try to find out on
the one hand whether anything's going to
happen after we do die and on the other
hand whether the fact that we're going
to die should affect how we live these
are two of the central issues that
everybody faces so how does a
professional philosopher go about
philosophizing about death what
questions must or ought to be asked in
order to come to any satisfying
conclusions in your own mind about what
it is and what it means for us
well methodologically speaking I think
about
the way I think about any philosophical
topic which is basically thinking
philosophers don't do empirical research
typically although there are a few that
do mostly what we do is we gather the
information we can whatever arguments or
thoughts people have had and we try to
think about these in a rigorous
systematic critical way asking ourselves
what kinds of positions can be put
forward what kinds of arguments for them
can be put forward how we might respond
to objections to those arguments so
that's how I think about any
philosophical topic and I think about
death in the same way of course the
thing about doing philosophy is that you
don't get definitive answers in the
sense that you're never going to find
answers to these questions that all
people will agree to or for that matter
even all philosophers there's a sense in
which philosophical questions are the
questions that almost by definition we
have a hard time trying to figure out
how to make progress on and so although
there are a number of positions in
philosophy in general death and with
regard to death in particular where I've
come up two answers to my own
satisfaction it's not really as though
there's anything where I'm completely a
hundred percent satisfied in the sense
that I think I could persuade everybody
or have answers to all possible worries
so talk to us a little bit about some of
the conclusions you have drawn well my
own view is that I suppose most
sensually that there's no such thing as
a soul at least if what we mean by soul
is something immaterial something
non-physical something distinct from
above and beyond the body most people at
least believe in a soul or the
possibility of a soul and then that
holds up for them the the real
possibility that something might
continue after the body dies in decays I
don't believe there is a soul I think
what we are what a person is is simply a
body that's able to talk as we're doing
it to think about questions like what
we're doing to communicate to make plans
to fall in love so I think we're just
bodies and as a result the death of our
body is the end of the death of my body
will be the end of my existence as a
person and I think that's the central
to realize about the nature of death
from which much of the rest follows so
what are some of the consequences for
the way that you perceive your own life
where you live your own life you know
that derive from that belief well I
suppose most centrally if you believe in
the possibility of an afterlife then you
might think that the central goal here
in this world is to live in such a way
as to maximize your happiness get into
heaven rather than Hell in in the world
to come since I don't believe there is
any kind of afterlife the focus
certainly needs to be this worldly we
have to then ask ourselves how should I
live with an eye towards how I am
interacting with others and what I'm
achieving for myself in this world do
you find that your students in your
philosophy classes come to have some of
the same come to some of the same
conclusion that you have or do you find
that they're wildly divergent well I
don't survey the students and so it's
not as though I can say okay before they
hear the lectures here's what they're
thinking after I hear the like after
they heard lectures here's what they're
thinking I do know based on
conversations I have with them and their
papers present and their papers that now
many many students don't share my views
and don't end up sharing my views on the
one hand I want to say that's fine
because of course the primary goal for
me as teacher of the class is to get
students to think critically about these
issues to take a hard look at some of
the views they may have held and ask
themselves whether or not these views
will withstand critical examination so
as long as they're doing that it's okay
with me if they don't end up agreeing
with me although on the other hand of
course I believe that my views are
correct and so I'm up front with them
about this in the Deaf class that I'm
going to to lay out the arguments as
best I can and I hope they'll end up if
they don't already growth me at the
outset I hope they'll come around but I
don't actually have any statistics as to
how many minds I change let me ask you a
question that is perhaps less an
intellectual question but I think a very
human one do you ever find thinking
about death so much depressing
and if not why not I don't actually find
it a depressing topic I find a
fascinating topic and I and I greatly
enjoyed discussing these issues both in
the class and and and writing about them
in the class and and in my writings I
try to keep a fairly light tone it's a
heavy subject but we don't have to
discuss it in morose or ponderous
academic manners so I try to keep a
fairly light touch but but that's not to
say that death isn't itself a serious
subject on various ways a sad one I mean
the loss of a loved one is is a horrible
thing to undergo and we all face that
the fact that I'm going to die that
you're going to die is in many ways sad
because I think we're going to die in
typical cases at least we're going to
die well before we've exhausted the
riches the life can offer us and so
that's horrible so there are many sad
aspects of death but I'd but it doesn't
make me sad to think about it to teach
it so have you come to a conclusion in
your own mind about whether death is
good or bad given that it can have some
what we think of as certainly as
negative repercussions for those of us
who survive for example loved ones who
died before that's a very complicated
question which let me just touch upon a
couple of aspects first of all is the
very fact that we're going to die bad
would immortality be good I suppose that
most of us believe that immortality
would be good it's precisely because of
that fact or that thought that we hope
or maybe even believe that we have a
soul so as to hold out the prospect of
immortality my own view not unique to me
but my own view is that immortality
would not be good that if we actually
lived forever life would become tedious
dreadful horrible a punishment rather
than some sort of reward
so the fact per se of our mortality is
good but that's compatible with thinking
that nonetheless we all die too soon the
fact that after thousands or tens of
thousands of however long it might be of
years I might grow bored doesn't mean
that I will have
grown bored grown bored by the time I
died and my own view is no I'm I think
the world such an amazing place that I
wish I had at least hundreds of years
more probably far longer than that and
so I think one aspect of death that's
bad is the fact that most of us die
while there's still good things in life
that could be coming our way
let's take a few questions from the
public
okay we've got one from a gentleman
called eat I'm a tile and he emailed us
this question I'm gonna read it to you
death is often conceived as the
irreversible loss of life as constrained
by the limits of modern medicine the
loss of all brain function for a person
is typically thought of as the line
beyond which death begins because there
is no current scientific means of
reversing it but if that too could be
reversed by some future science what
would it then mean to die I think that's
innate it's a wonderful question what
exactly should we say is though is the
conceptual definition of death the
empirical criteria that we use to
determine when somebody's dead may very
used to be when the heart had stopped
beating when person had stopped
breathing
now as the question remarks it has to do
with when brain functioning has ceased
but but those aren't what it is to die
per se we might say and my own view is
that to die per se is to lose the
ability for the body there which is all
we are just bodies that have abilities
to do things so to die is to lose
certain subsets of the abilities we
normally have in particular the sorts of
abilities that are tied to being a
person the sorts of things I was
gesturing towards an earlier our ability
to communicate our rationality our
ability to plan to be creative to fall
in love to write poetry and the like
it's the it's the loss of those
abilities now the crucial point here is
it's not the temporary loss because well
when you're sleep you're not reciting
poetry you're not communicating but we
might say pushing a little bit harder
you're still able to do those things and
so the question is when are the bodily
structures sufficiently broken that it
can no longer be done now I'm inclined
to think that there could in principle
be signed
cific break through such that it
wouldn't be true to say wouldn't be
accurate to say the person never really
died in principle it might be accurate
to say the person did dive the abilities
were lost the body was broken but for
all that we are now able to bring the
person back alive to give a either
fanciful or religious example imagine
the Judgment Day comes and God
resurrects the dead the bodies have
decomposed and the atoms then get
recollected by gaudí reassembles them in
the right way and turns the body back on
the correct thing to say in that
situation is not that we were never
really dead at all rather God
resurrected the dead he brought the dead
back to life now if somehow amazingly
enough science were to make similar
technological breakthroughs and we were
to be able to similarly reassemble the
atoms that would be turning the person
back on but it wouldn't be correct to
say he hadn't really died so not all the
scientific breakthroughs that the
question it was asking about mean that
the person wasn't really dead so and you
you you reference this in some of your
earlier remarks but what would what
would infinite life mean then well of
course one thing and when we think about
immortality we have to get clear about
how are we imagining it
if we simply imagine extrapolating out
life on the kind of curve that we
currently have where old age brings
sickness and disease loss of memory or
other cognitive functions then of course
it's easy to believe that immortality
would be just dreadful this is a
familiar point Jonathan Swift actually
has a quite interesting passage in
Gulliver's Travels where he imagines
Gulliver discovering a little subset of
people who live forever but indeed they
live in this horribly degraded state and
it's horrible
clearly when people imagine the
desirability of immortality they're
trying to correct for that and so the
real question is can we imagine any way
for immortality to be good and you know
throw in whatever fantasy conditions you
want to put in that we're always healthy
that we're always wealthy that we can
have whatever it is you want that you
can
change your career change your partner
if that matters to you whatever it might
be is there any kind of life describable
at all that you could really imagine
being attractive for a billion years
a hundred billion years a trillion years
all I can say is when I've done my best
to try to imagine such a life I'm unable
to do it and to simply say oh of course
it would be desirable I think is to fail
to face the question let's take another
question from the public this one is
from Shoshana Kaufman and she asks if
you're familiar with the work of rabid
rabbi Dovid Gottlieb a philosopher who's
inspired her whether you are or not
I would ask how you as a philosopher
approach the question of death
differently from say of theologian good
so now I don't know that rabbis work so
how does a philosopher in general think
about questions like this as opposed to
a theologian one thing that a theologian
has access to is what they take to be
revelation whose typical theologians
have revealed truths you might think
that the Bible is in some way divinely
inspired or the Koran or what have you
and you then it will also typically have
some kind of tradition within the church
or your whatever your religion might be
that has answers has put forward answers
and so a theologian can appeal to those
kinds of authorities the philosopher
typically again there are exceptions but
typically tries to think about questions
like this without making use of these
kinds of religious answers it's not so
much that we're dismissing the religious
answers as we're dismissing the appeal
to religious authority and so we go
about asking ourselves what would we
believe about these questions if we
limited ourselves to what we could know
using human reason it's perfectly
compatible with that to think that there
are these additional sources of
information but then that raises a whole
host of other questions namely do we
have reason to believe in God - a reason
to believe that the Bible is divinely
revealed and so forth what does it mean
to say that it's divinely revealed and
although as a philosopher one could
think about those questions as well and
in certain moods
do when I'm thinking about death I
basically just bracket religious
questions and ask myself what conclusion
should we hold about death putting aside
whatever answers religion itself might
try to argue for so is it possible then
for a philosopher in your mold to have a
real conversation with a theologian or
would you not inevitably come to a point
where you had to dismiss an argument
that the theologian was presenting on I
could certainly have such conversations
and I have had conversations with
theologians I mean theologians like any
other thinking individual tries to
persuade a field oh don't try to
persuade you of their views based on
whatever evidence they think is
appropriate to bring to bear including
their religious traditions at a certain
point in such conversations the that the
the conversation may need to steer away
from the topic you were originally
talking about in the way I would just
suggest in a moment of go and turn to
questions do we believe how should we
talk should we interpret the Bible let's
say or what evidence do we have for
Revelation and the like and then you can
have quite interesting discussions with
them as well on those topics theologians
are often to a significant significant
degree just philosophers are
specializing in a set of religious
topics of course as you suggest at a
certain point you may have to agree to
disagree or say look we've run out of
time we're not gonna be able to settle
the questions whether or not the problem
of evil establishes the non-existence of
God but that situation is no different
from the situation I face when I'm
talking with another professional
philosopher precisely because the
philosophical questions are ones where
reasonable people can disagree and so
often you say okay I see where you're
coming from I see how you weighing up
the various pros and cons I weigh them
up differently or here's some other
issues we'll have to get to next time
let's take another question this one
from Veronica guimarães via Twitter she
asks and again we've addressed this
somewhat but it's a kind of question you
can take on you know infinitely I think
what would the meaning of death be sort
of the answer for the meaning of life
that is is there really a difference
it's a common enough thought that these
two questions are very
tightly connected Kafka said at one
point of a meaning of life is that it
ends suggesting that the fact that we
die is in fact the essential thing to
think about in thinking about the
meaning of life I myself think that's
that's wrong I mean I think there are
certain implications for how we should
live when we think about or we get clear
about the facts about death if if it's
if I'm right in thinking that the death
of my body will be the end of my
existence as a person if there won't be
any do-overs there won't be any second
time around
then that has significant implications
about how careful we need to be able how
careful we need to be when we're living
to make sure we we we live appropriately
that we pick the right goals that we
interact with people in the right way
that we that we don't waste our life in
terms of what we set what the goals we
set ourselves are but that doesn't tell
us what the appropriate goals are and I
think the question of the meaning of
life is indeed the question so how
should you live and so although death
has and the facts about death have some
bearing on that they don't actually
settle in any central way the central
question how should we live what's the
meaning of life that's it's a it's a
matter for further philosophical
reflection so how is your understanding
of death changed over time as you've
considered it and considered it and
considered it more what are some of the
most radical changes was there a time
when you didn't believe that the end of
your body was the end of your life some
of my philosophical views my early
philosophical views are lost in the
mists of time because I thought about
things from a philosophical point of
view from a fairly early age and so if
you ask me I can think of certain
philosophical questions I was thinking
about at the age of 8 9 10 so if you ask
me at that time did I believe in a soul
I know a material soul
I no longer remember the answer although
I rather suspect that I did but I don't
remember having lost that belief and so
I'm not confident that I did if you're
asking rather all right think about your
professional life you know from you from
your 20s on how of my views about death
changed
I suppose in broad strokes they haven't
it's many more of the details that is
there are any number of philosophical
questions we've been skimming the
surface here but there are some
complicated philosophical questions
about the precise definition of death or
what are the best arguments for or
against the existence of a soul or how
exactly it could be that death is bad
for you since you won't exist how can
anything be bad if it's right the death
is the end then you won't exist after
the death your death so how can anything
be bad for you then but definitely seem
is a curious ancient Greek philosopher
famously said look death isn't bad for
you now you're live and death won't be
bad for you once you're dead you won't
exist then so death he concluded can't
be bad for you very few of us find that
argument persuasive but trying to figure
out what exactly is the answer to where
does that argument go wrong that's far
from obvious and so there are questions
of that sort though that have my views
have shifted and deep continue to shift
I'm some some issues I'm I'm pretty much
up in the air about another question has
just come in pardon me what do you think
one feels after death
good so since I believe that death is
the end I mean just think about it if
you ask yourself what happens to the
movie what happens in the movie after
the movies over well the answer that's
pretty obvious nothing happens in the
movie after the movies over suppose you
ask what kind of music is your boombox
making after you've dropped it and it's
broken and the answer is it's not making
any kind of music so I think that
feeling things having experiences having
thoughts having emotions these are
things that my body is doing right now
while it's functioning and death is the
breaking of the ability the loss of the
ability to do those things and so I
think the death is the end of thinking
the death of death is the end of feeling
death is the end of thought and and an
emotion and so the answer is it won't
feel like anything there are no thoughts
that will be had there are no feelings
there there'll be nothing that it's like
to be dead where it's important to
understand that that doesn't mean being
dead is like something but unlike
everything else so there's nothing that
else
it's like I mean there's nothing that
it's like to give an example that I
talked about in the book or a class if
you were to pick up a ballpoint pen and
ask what does it feel like to be a
ballpoint pen the answer is ballpoint
pens don't have feelings there is
nothing that it feels like to be a
ballpoint pen I think the same thing is
the right answer to say about what will
feel like when you're dead there's
nothing that it will feel like because
you won't have any feelings at all okay
we're gonna take one more from the
public this one is from Miriam she asks
what do you think about the end of the
world in relation to your views about
death gosh that's a question that stumps
me a little bit I'm not sure I thought
about it in that connection since I do
think that it's bad for most people in
most circumstances there are cases
tragically where you die in the prime of
your life but you've been ill I mean
you're young but you've been ill and so
perhaps in those cases death isn't bad
for you it gives you relief from your
pain and suffering most of us will die
as I said earlier too soon and so I'm
not quite sure what the question is
imagining about the end of the world I
mean suppose that the sun's supernovas
and somehow people are still alive on
the earth oh that would be a horrible
tragedy beyond the the loss of the
individual lives the the end of the
world unless we've managed to colonize
other planets or other star systems or
perhaps she means the end of the
universe it's not quite clear how grand
when she imagined the world ending if
you imagine the end of the human race
there's a certain kind of moral loss
there that goes above and beyond the sum
of the loss of individual people
I think if humanity does not continue
that itself is a certain kind of tragedy
and so although I'm not sure that death
per se brings that in because in normal
circumstances when we die or there's
plenty of others around and and and
hopefully their long beat up is around
if if if the world ends and there are no
people around at that point that will be
horrible in a special unique way let me
ask one final question here of a
different vein what do you make of your
popularity in China which has been
reported on on China national radio it
it's been a remarkable experience
so once the open Yale class the death
class was was put online I started
getting emails from people around the
world which was wonderful and then after
all a large percentage of them started
coming from from China and this this
surprised me I had no particular
expectations it's quite clear that death
lectures are not sure exactly there it
people are resonating to them for
reasons that aren't 100 percent clear
there's there's some reason to think
that they are attracted to the fact that
I'm talking about important
philosophical issues but I'm not simply
citing authorities I don't talk about
here's what Kant thought here's what
Aristotle thought I do say some things
about some historical figures but for
the most part I'm speaking in my own
voice and so I think people find that
attractive there's also some reason to
think the evidence is indirect but
there's some reason to think that the
visuals are playing a role I lecture in
my classes dressed more or less the way
you see me in jeans sneakers typically a
plaid shirt Lanna shirt I'm sitting
cross-legged on my desk I seem to have
tapped into some ancient Chinese
stereotypes about ancient sages and so I
think part of the popularity is here's a
sage speaking about issues which they
don't cover in typical Chinese education
well shelly kagan thank you so much for
joining us I wish we could talk all
afternoon this has been great fun
perhaps you join us again it's been a
real pleasure thank you for having me
and thanks to all of you for joining us
we hope that you'll tune in again we're
going to speak with Yale psychologist
Kelly Brownell we'll have details on
that on the Yale News website in the
future thanks very much